e
well catastrophic was separate right I
noticed
e
okay I'd like to welcome the public to
our meeting today this is the education
funding committee and we are here today
looking at 14 bills of which we broke
them down into categories as they're
listed and I I'll go through that in a
second and we will be taking some e
executive sessions throughout the day um
after we finish these various categories
for the members on the committee here
what we have you have the bill lineup
That that we have for today the agenda
you can see the first four bills HB 717
742 773 and 603 are all related to
special
education so what we're going to be
doing is we're going to be discussing
these bills then we're going to be we
know that on March 4 we have to move a
bill forward dealing with special
education these are early bills and so
one of them will be used as the vehicle
to go forward and then we will also try
to uh perhaps retain a bill to work on
it because this this particular issue
and I met with several folks yesterday
represent luno and and representative
Earth and and um the issue of special
education Aid formly catastrophic age is
huge and you're all familiar with the
formula now when 3 and 1/2 times 3 and
1/2 x times up to 10 that's becomes
responsibility of the combination of the
state and and the local 8020 but the
first three and a half is that of the
local $770,000 roughly if used 20,000 as
the average per pupil
cost and we're trying to identify if we
moved the
responsibility of the Lo local down to
up to 2 and a half or three a lesser
amount than now what would that what
would that entail what would it include
as far as numbers of
students it's very difficult to find
that information out and quite frankly
we haven't been able to get an accurate
number on that Doe does not have that
when you have that breakoff three and a
half times going forward you're talking
about the catastrophic agid you're
talking about those 800 students
that are are very expensive students in
terms of costing out special education
but if you try to build back finding out
how many kids would be in that two and a
half to three and a half level we start
seeing that curved all a sudden Spike go
really high because that's where the
other 30,000 kids are that have IEPs in
that category there and going backwards
but the majority are start somewhere
starting to be down that two times two
and a half times and so we bring it back
down that way what are we going to do to
the upper end of States proportion it's
going to be we're going to see
projections in the future go Way Beyond
the 50 million mark up above 60 million
and we have Mark here today which can
help us out a little bit but that's not
his baileywick either he his baileywick
is that of trying to help with the
financial numbers he does not work for
the special ed department so um that's
where we stand right here here so if we
look at these bills right now first of
are there any questions on the process
we're going to take those four first
four bills then we go into the next
three bills we notice they're all swep
bills and we will deal with the issue of
swep do we how do we address the swep
issue which we know is a very huge issue
in this state the next five bills listed
some May six but five down through
772 are dealing with our adequate
formula and so we're going to take these
groups the last one the the the five 675
Bill we will take up but that also deals
some issues Beyond just the adequacy
talks about a cap and other such things
and 510 is a bill which deals with due
processes separate from the issue of
funding for this students in this regard
of special education or or swep or the
foundation formula
so without spinning our Wheels a whole
lot more I'd like to go right back to
the top the first four bills right now
and look at 717 742 773 and 603 let's
first what 717 does it says goes from 3
and 1/2 time 3 and 1/2x and breaks it
down to
three that's the general Twist of that
bill it's one which just looks at the
catastrophic Aid
formula and it would go up to three
times then three times to 10 times and
10 times Beyond 100% to the
state so backing It Off from three and
A2 to three we're not sure what that
would cost mark do you have any
information that could help
us understand that a little bit better I
know we played with numbers all day
yesterday
um does everybody is everybody familiar
with Mark
here he's a frequent flyer here from doe
thank you good morning Mark Mello Bureau
of school Finance um uh yeah chairman
ladin and nhed met um just to discuss
this issue this has been an ongoing
issue as far
as data once you hit
$70,000 uh $70,000 in special education
special education expenditures you
submit claims to the uh Bureau of
special education for reimbursement so
we have data on any costs that are above
70,000 because you can get paid for it
any cost below 70,000 wouldn't make its
way to the Department of Education so we
don't know the exercise um that I
believe the Bureau of special education
is working on I don't know if they'll be
successful and the exercise we walked
through chairman lad with um was could
we make any sort of forecast about how
many students might exist within that
cost range of 3 to 3.5 or 2.5 to
3.5 and uh what we're struggling with is
we know there's 800 at 800 out of around
31,000 students 800 a very small amount
that have cost above
3.5 so we know there's a lot of students
around 31,000 or so that are below that
but where they fall and what bucket they
fall into we are trying to
forecast what the slope might be or what
the curve might be we expect more
students to be on that lower end uh less
students to be on that higher end and
we're we're trying to come up with a
number that we feel like we could
present to you um but um I don't want to
be pessimistic here but I wouldn't keep
my hopes up I think this is really hard
for us to do um so the Bureau of special
education is looking into that to see if
they can give you a count of where we
think how claims would come in that 3 to
3.5 or 2.5 to 3.5 but the the basic
answer is we don't know um can we come
up with an estimate that might be
reasonable maybe so that's where we're
at with that there and when you talk
about this it's sort of like this you
can see you know on on this this is 10
times over here getting down to three
and a half times you go down lower and
you can see how this line spikes right
up and so we having a hard time figuring
out what these costs are so represent
Lun did you have a question or you know
add to a conversation yeah no no a
question for Mark so thank you very much
Mr chair how is the um um how how is the
average the Statewide average cost per
pupil
calculated um so um there's the one used
for special education Aid yes yeah the
one we're talking about right um so um
the special education one it's an
estimate and so we do um we basically do
um we look at
ms22 budgets and we do kind of a budget
an uh budget to actual analysis and we
send that to the special education
Bureau so it's a forecast of where we
think the actual cost per pup based on
the doe 25s is going to land we try to
mimic that by looking at budget to
actual from the previous year and then
apply those percentages essentially out
there's more to it than that but
essentially and and and our estimates
have come within a pretty pretty close
Okay so so just to be just to be clear
the the the average cost per um make
sure I get the language right here uh
the estimated State average expenditure
per pupil um includes special education
expenditures correct okay thank you any
other yes represent
fellows thank you uh so one thing we
should one number we could get is if you
took the most recent catastrophic a
distribution and you just changed the
three and 1/2 to three so that's going
to tell you one number and then we know
that any new ones that would be coming
on because we're dropping the number
would be fairly small I do have that
number so if we go to let's see how
quickly I can do it but if we go from
3.5 to 2.5 at a minimum Bas on those 8
uh 57 students we know we have cost for
we cover everything after 70k so if we
were going to cover everything 80% of
50k to 70k which would be 2.5x to
3.5x um I calculated that to be 13.6
million so at a minimum you're paying
13.6 million to go down to the
2.5x but just follow up yes go ahead so
but this bill is three and you just told
me yeah so let me do three see if I can
do three real quick I think you can do
half of that is that maybe yeah it would
be yeah the Del the variance yeah okay
yeah
6.8
representa is something I apologize for
blurting out out of turn I uh got
excited hearing data um so you were
saying Mark that uh and thank you for
being here that that 13.8 million that
you were talking about would just be the
C for the students that are already over
3.5 correct it does not include the new
students who would start popping up in
that data set that's correct that number
is a minimum minimum funding point just
wanted to understand what we're working
with thank
you this is what you're talking about
that you get now Jen can we get some
copies this made please uh enough for
the
committee back to back shows how this
thank you very
much reprend
Damon thank you Mr chair and thank you
for helping us with
this I'm probably asking the obvious but
I guess I need to hear it verified so
districts do
not track or have the numbers that we're
talking about they can't tell us how
many students are in the 2 and a half
times the estimated average or
three times estimated average uh so so
you could do a so the department could
do a survey where we ask districts for
that information um it would be
voluntary information and they wouldn't
receive funding for it so the you could
ask the bureau Bureau of special
education to go through that exercise um
they would be basically doing a survey
and districts would if they filled out
the survey I believe they could answer
that question so short answer to that is
no the department does not have that the
short answer is we've not done that no
I'm not aware of that survey being
done yes yes you may so I understand the
department doesn't have that
information but my question is do the
districts already have that information
they're just not required to share it so
they could go through the exercise
how they could go through the exercise
uh the data they ultimately have the
students and the cost um um I don't know
how readily available it be or if
they've already have it I'm not sure
they have the data I just don't know how
EAS they can grab it and report it thank
you yes represent Ricky so I I um have
just a so are we
talking 2.5 times or three times because
the bill says three times but so are we
or are we just trying to make talk in
general we could be talking two and a
half three three and a half whatever
this just how this whole thing works or
doesn't work or doesn't yes thanks and
then yes represent yeah so thanks very
much Mr chair and and so Mark um um
uh I I think I personally I I think it
would be a a good request from the um a
good ask from the Department to
districts to try to get a better
understanding as to as to um the um you
know how the how the costs would go down
to and I don't know pick a number that
that the chair has you know talked about
you know two or 2 and a half or
something like that maybe deeper than
than we're going to go but at least we
can cover that and try to model what
that what that curve uh actually looks
like but but um it you know it seems it
it seems unlikely to me that that
districts would have access to that data
already because you know that would
require tracking cost by
student by individual and and so I I
guess how how do districts know when
right now when to start tracking costs
on a per student basis because obviously
they're expecting reimbursement when
they when they or 80% coverage once they
exceed three and a half times but but
how do they know when they've gotten to
three and a half times are they cross
yeah at what threshold do they so so
definitely the Bureau of special
education and the field could give you
more detailed information but
mechanically uh this Bureau of special
education publishes that standard early
before the school year starts or sorry
now let me think about the mechanics of
it yeah they give them advanced notice
of that number so they've been flagged
as far as hey when your cost rece start
70,000 yeah they're aware of that number
and then the number doesn't change that
much year-over-year so they know the
program so whatever systems districts
develop locally to flag high cost
students okay to be queued up for that
invoicing process ejected by ejected by
the
department and there's got to be common
Data Systems available which I think
they're working on that right now we're
in a transition stage right now and so
and also separating out some of those
Medicaid costs too within that system
well and transportation and
transportation that's exactly right so
but there are some that are and when
they come for three and a half they say
oh we're there some of those costs
within are not accepted so that when
when a district with three and a half
less submits all this stuff to they're
all going to have to be reviewed to see
if they do make that
Mark yeah reps spilsbury so everything
with respect to data which would
inform you know our decisions about
spending uh operates on a lag time even
today uh the doe doesn't get the figures
uh relative to the three and a half
threshold and reimbursement until the
end of the year MH almost anything that
we do is probably likely to have a
2-year transition just before we'd start
to see meaningful data I think there's a
couple of different ways of getting
there and I think we have a pretty
strong consensus that uh if we're going
to manage this better we're going to
need better data one way would be to
just simply pass a law that requires the
district to submit this even though it's
a burden on them and they're getting
nothing for it and and that might be uh
a difficult uh
uptake uh another way is uh you know to
start plan ahead and look at the
Medicaid um reimbursement uh systems
which I understand are going through a
uh a transition into a new much more
integrated uh approach and uh if
districts have to comply with the
Medicaid
requirements then we can piggy back off
of that perhaps Sy on further degree a
third one I suppose you know in in some
ways we're all fundamentally
uncomfortable with is to just leap into
the dark um so one way to find out how
many students and uh we we know what
we're talking about here if we're
talking two and a half times is a
$20,000 band loow the threshold from
approximately 70 to
50 so how do you leap into the dark
right and and you don't know how to
budget it what it's going to cost one
way to do that is to uh to change the
percentage of the cost share so for
example I'm very open to the idea of
lowering the threshold but I wouldn't be
willing to lower the Threshold at an 80%
State
share would 50% be the appropriate uh
division for that next lower tier
perhaps to atable but a way of getting
to the data would be to lower the
threshold to 2 and2 and put in something
like a 10% State share so that the
districts are getting something but
we're hedging our bets until we get the
data so you don't just want to throw
that thought out there to to to to take
the step at a lower threshold but put it
at an extraordinarily lower threshold
in a transitionary phase and then you
will get the data at least down that far
representative spilsbury is talking
about a component that we have not
talked about is between 3.5x the cost
per pupil and 10x we pay 80% of that so
if you wanted to pay 100% of that that's
a number we know that would cost $10
million so if you wanted to increase the
state's share you can increase
Appropriations and fund that or if you
want to decrease the state's share you
could instead of 80% make it a lesser
number Etc and you would spend less
money um so that's another variable part
of this formula and as representative
spillsbury was saying uh uh bringing
down from 2 3x 2 2.5x whatever you don't
you could modify your share you don't
have to pay state law determines how
much of the state's going to pay
currently it's 80% um our modeling is
assuming 80% but that's another variable
you can change Mark looking at your
modeling and projecting out for FY 27
and going
further and I'm not I'm not talking FY
26 I'm going out further um when that
occurs and there I I I'm seeing a
likelihood of the number of students
here increasing and the costs increasing
right now we're at about $50 million and
I believe that what the governor's done
is basically put in $16 million to make
that difference up between the 54 34 and
and
50 is there another way of doing this uh
in case that the costs for that cat Aid
Spike that we can save the districts
from having to deal with this pration
amount which could be prated down to 30%
or 60% or at 68% right now if we put
that pration amount at 100% or
90% um is that way of also saving these
districts in terms of and planning that
we we know this is what the state budget
is and we know that it's not going to
come back to haunt us with a pration
amount where we're not going to receive
what we think we should be receiving and
now we move to the other variable we
haven't talked about um the budget
appropriation and so um where special
education Aid can get a little bit
confusing is because you've got the
80% State's liability number but then
you have the pration the pration is
based on how much we budgeted and how
much it cost us and if the budget
Appropriations don't match the full cost
the full liability and that's what the
governor has funded based on current
data um we can talk about future data in
a second but based on current data the
cost of the liability to the state as
established in RSA is going to be 50
million we had uh 34 million so we're 16
million short so we had to Pro special
education Bureau had to Pro uh Pro rate
out down to 68% so they couldn't fund 50
million because they had 34 million so
they had to give everyone basically a
hair cut down to 68% and then allocated
out the cost there so what the governor
has done is said she's allocated in her
budget uh uh 16 million to bring us up
to 15 50 million with the expectation if
everything holds there would be no
pration we would we' essentially get up
to that 100% instead of being
68% now what chairman lad is talking
about is could we do something um uh to
modify that and division 2 has talked
about this a little bit what you could
do to always ensure you hit your number
is have an open warrant in the ETF so if
there is a $16 million shortfall then
give uh the Department of Education
authority to draw down that fund from
the education trust fund to plug that um
and then pration would would never exist
it would always fund the liability is
established in RSA um not be limited to
what is the budget appropriation so
that's the mechanism there to address
pration is essentially the ability to
access Appropriations outside of the
budget so is
that reference what represent luno put
forth in his represent luno why don't
you you have a bill too that does sort
of that right right and and and look
thank you Mr chair and what's what's
great about these packages of bills is
that they provide a lot of different
approaches to the to the solution so so
um so what what Mark was just talking
about where where um where you eliminate
the appropriation in the budget you
change the law to have the um the
state's liability to special education
Aid paid directly from the education
trust fund and then you have the
Overflow clause which I think is common
in in education trust fund where where
if the fund doesn't have the money
enough money in it the governor shall
issue a warrant to draw from
unappropriate or available General funds
to uh to fuel the education trust fund
um and there's there's no pration so
that's House Bill
742 um and that's so that that's an
option that would uh would eliminate the
um the pration but I also I wanted to go
back to what representative spillsbury
was suggesting too in terms of maybe
collecting some data from 2 and A2 to
three and a half and um and and you know
providing a little bit of incentive to
districts to collect and submit that
data and um and and you know maybe
rather than rather than a percentage you
know 10% or whatever put a dollar amount
in there as well as a pration clause so
that so that the the the state's
basically paying I don't know pick the
number $10 million to to to or $5
million to collect the data and um and
and have it
stretch
um going down to uh you know whatever
whatever you there there there are
several ways of handling this and
there's also just setting the pration up
a percentage high right right right so
no I'm talking about just I think but
what we're talking about in this
discussion here is there's a lot of
information we need to obtain from the
districts MH and I don't think it's
readily available and it they may have
it but it has to be reviewed to ensure
that it's good accurate information the
invoices stack up to what is acceptable
for that
IEP and uh I I think what we have to do
here is that within the time we have
here to look at this this an early Bill
we're going to have to put something
forward but we're also going to have to
hold something back and look at this
whole the whole nature of how we're what
we're doing here in terms of making some
kind of recommendations and Gathering
more information on how we're going to
handle this I understood when we're
talking FY 27 or so this that number
could Spike Beyond 50 million bucks and
and we could be we could you know have
skyrocketing Affairs if that 2 and 1/2
to three and A2 is really full of those
kids which crowd of we're now accepting
them we could end up burying the
education trust fund just like that and
not having a borrow take it out of the
general fund uh and how how that goes so
the thing needs to be looked at so I
think we're going to have to do
something we're going to have to pass
something to whether it's the what
represent luno just said or it's later
that pration bill we set the pration
amount high or and I I personally am
very fearful of backing off to two and a
half or to three right now when we don't
know what we're talking about but on the
other side with the pration stuff we we
are trying to protect the Local District
from unfunded costs that are going to
come to them so what would happen though
if if these numbers really creased like
an FY 27 Mark if it jumped up to $65
million if if it jumped up to 65 and you
enacted an open warrant yeah you would
be your your budget EST and you budgeted
for 50 yeah you would be 15 million over
budget it would it it would yeah it
would it would be a budget control issue
as as you mentioned well how how would
it how would it work if you had a
pration cap on there where the where the
appropriation was um was was less than
what the uh what the statute would
require would there would there be an
open warrant um
to adjust the
appropriation so I think what you're
describing is so if there were if if the
pration comes in at
70% BEC or similar to this year uh um
run a warrant up to 80% something like
that then yeah that would be that would
be less that would cost the full 15
million under that scenario so you it's
it'd be splitting you know oh you'd have
to have that language and
statute um uh um yeah you would want to
make it clear um because the department
could has to be kind of black and white
as far as giving out those funds I don't
think I I don't know unless you can get
creative with the legislation I would
think it's kind of uh um yeah you might
have to study that does does 717 have
the
77 is just dealing with the one thing of
of the the three and a half to three
right then there's another one which we
have which is oh I'm sorry I'm talking
about 773 773 yes 773 needs some work if
we use it it it be easy work um and it
may be the way we go for example if we
rais the pration amount you know I was
looking let's say we had the $16 million
for short right now and if we had a
pration amount of
90% we be shallow quick math my head
probably somewhere around $1.5
million um that's palatable but
68 68% is not
so looking at and this is a bill
representative Vlad introduced 773 I
think you're missing a warrant in that
Bill yes the warrant's not in this bill
so we need the we need the open the the
warrant language for sure yeah you need
that you need to scratch out what's been
eliminated in line six
through
n and you may want to play with the
pration mount it says 85% there those
are easy amendments to guarantee that to
guarantee a particular pration number
you need a open warrant yeah right yeah
yes
representa if we are looking to um you
know kind of figure out the language
that may be acceptable to the committee
and you know finalize an amendment for
the next time cu the time is short I
would suggest that you know probably 773
would be a good candidate for the sped
uh you know the one that we just
discussed which is um you
know allowing for
that bottom to the pration where it
cannot go past the specific amount
adding in the language that repr luno
just mentioned well that's up to the
committee but basically my concern on
the finance side is what was just
expressed that a fixed appropriation we
can work with but a open warrant is a
very risky thing since we've seen
massive swings in this number so I
cannot speak for how finance will look
upon it if we take too much risk here
but you know giving something us
something to work with would be great
and I think this has some of the
components that you know would be useful
to try to address this at least make
some progress in the short term because
God knows right now we don't have enough
data to fix it fix it you know part of
what we are discussing so here here's a
thought that we use 773 as the vehicle
and get an amendment made we agree on
that keep one of these bills maybe
represented as luno Bill as a retain
motion so we have something to work on
two how's that how's that sound I think
we're good with that everybody putting
their heads up and down and okay so what
we ought to do2 so what we will we'll do
is we'll we'll put a small group
together here uh to repesent Luna I want
you on that I want represent spillsbury
on it repes you know uh representative
uh you you can't do it can you Keith cuz
here you can't this is just a meat for
fact we don't even have to do it as a
subcommittee we can just work this
amendment up bring bring the amendment
back and act on that in March
4 and and so what we could do right now
is dump the other two and retain one and
then we can get on to the next category
which is
budget can you just repeat what are the
things we want to put to to amend it no
what what we're not going to do anything
with the amending right now we're going
to get a I'll get a small group here
together we'll put an amendment together
get that to everybody prior to March 4
and and then we'll act on it on March 4
I don't think we have you know we are
limited with some time today so uh I
think this that will work uh what I'd
like to do is just take a a brief five
minute caucus so the luno can explain to
your people what we're doing it's sort
of what we discussed the other day and I
I will meet with this caucus right here
we'll come back in about five minutes at
you know five of 11 and and and dump two
retain one and and not take any action
on the other one until we
caucus
e
okay I'd like to go ahead now
and uh I'd like to uh ask we're going to
603 I Look to represent spillsbury for a
motion thank you Mr chair I move itl on
hp603 is there a second represent luno
makes that second is there any further
discussion from the maker of the
motion uh no I think we've we've got a
strategy that allows us to focus on the
uh uh approaches that we can get support
for uh just Simply Having a bill that
makes one huge increase in in the uh
directed aid for special Aid is not uh
an approach that uh that we can move
ahead with and represent luno yes thanks
and and while while while I appreciate
the sponsors of of 603 recognizing what
uh what a realistic cost is of um for
for for a student receiving special
education uh services at least on on
average I think it's one- siiz fits-all
approach um really isn't the right
direction for um for New Hampshire good
point any further
discussion okay Madam clerk when you're
ready we are
ready Vice chairman spills
fa
yes representative Maguire yes
representative Earth yes representative
kopal yes representative kcom yes
representative papovich yes
representative Brown yes representative
hian yes representative peoples yes
representative luno yes representative
Ames yes representative Burton yes
representative fellows yes
representative
Damon yes representative bricky yes
representative kitan yes representative
Weinstein yes chairman lad yes 18 yes
yeah you can do the report okay okay we
will close that one down and we'll go
into the executive session for 717 and
I'm going to hand the gabble off to
representative spillsbury
okay opening opening executive session
on HB
717 uh can I ask representative blad for
a motion yes I'd like to make the motion
of itl we'll second that itl seconded by
representative
luno any discussion yes we just had a
lengthy discussion about dropping back
to three 3x uh three times uh on the
catastrophic Aid um I think we recognize
we don't have the data to to make a move
to E3 or some other figure that's lower
so that's why I brought for the motion
of
itl would the second like to speak yeah
yes please um thank you very much Mr
chair I I um I I appreciate the um the
the the direction that 717 goes in terms
of um uh supporting school districts at
lower um um with with with in some of
the lower costs but they're still high
costs uh when it comes to the average
cost per um per pupil for special
education but U but I agree with what um
with what representative lad says we
don't have the data and um I'm hoping
that uh that maybe in a subsequent
amendment to a bill we might be able to
put some sort of incentive on there to
to collect data but we'll see how that
goes thank you thank you other
comments representative Damon do you
have a
comment no thank you Mike's on oh sorry
okay if if we're all set then I will ask
rooll chairman spills bearing yeah
representative Maguire yes
representative Earth yes representative
kopal yes representative kcom yes
representative papovich yes
representative Brown yes representative
mahagan yes representative peoples yes
representative Luna yes representative
Ames yes representative Burton yes
representative fellows yes
representative Damon yes representative
Ricky yes yes representative kitan yes
representative Weinstein yes and
no okay chairman lad you will write the
report I me yes okay very good you're
down are these last two on those two on
consent they have a itls I believe they
can be is there any objection to consent
on both 603
77 okay no I so I I don't see any
objections okay so the last one I want
to deal with right now is uh
742 uh this is requiring catastrophic
special education state aid funding to
be drawn from the education trust fund
I'm looking for a
motion I'll make a motion to retain I'll
second
that uh rep would you like to speak to
that so thanks thanks very much um the I
I I I think it makes good sense for this
committee to uh to uh retain some bills
that are relevant in these in these
areas uh given some moving parts that
are that are around there and I think
this bill uh uh includes the necessary
flexibility with which to U you know
with which to allow this committee to
retain okay I have no further discussion
that myself as second are is there any
committee thank you very much Madam
ready representative spillsbury yes
representative McGuire yes
representative Earth yes representative
copal yes representative kcom yes
representative papovich yes
representative Brown yes representative
mahagan yes representative peoples yes
representative Luna yes representative
Ames yes representative Burton yes
representative fellows yes
representative Damon yes representative
bricky yes representative Chan yes
representative Weinstein yes chairman
lad yes 18 y zero nay okay I'm going to
ask uh okay there's there's one other
bill which we're not going to take
action on now and that's 773
and that I'm going to ask that represent
spillsbury and represent luno get
together huddle and put together an
amendment for us please uh where we can
move forward this is dealing with
pration Etc and which we discussed and
we will take this bill up for exec
session on March
4 so as soon as you can get that
Amendment i' I'd ask that you you
request to get it done as quickly as
possible so it can get out to
everybody understood thank you you're
welcome and and so now we are ready to
go ahead into the next block of bills
and these are the swep Bills uh 527 739
and
734 uh looking at 527 let's turn there
there's there's the three bills I
believe 527 that was represented
fellow's bill um 739 was representative
spilsbury's Bill 734
was that was that your bill represent
Ames yeah
uh let's open up some general discussion
discussion okay I I'd like to start off
with the the the bottom Bill
734 um this bill has a component in it
which is interesting to me that we're
dealing with the State education
property tax and the amount that is paid
by those in communities which don't have
the
wherewithal to to you know pay that tax
and so it it has it builds in something
there in terms of where we have not had
any discussion on and this is something
that I think it's also a portion of the
other bill which I'm going to try to you
know get us to retain later on which is
the luno bill in terms of the foundation
formula which which is very very complex
we haven't seen any spreadsheets yet but
it's very complex and there's a lot of
components in it with that are are
interesting as well and and that we need
to have some time to discuss so you know
I'm asking that maybe on that particular
un represent ames's Bill we take that up
with the other Bill together in in a
retain motion and put our time after we
get rid of the stuff to division two and
they can have fun with what we send them
we will have some time to really dig
into these critical policy areas which
are impacting costing of education so
that's my two cents on 734 represent
Ames I think that's good sense uh and uh
I certainly would support that and uh in
fact the uh other Bill
772 has embedded in it this very same
bill so they're already set up for
working in that
way so then let's spend our time dealing
with uh 75 739 and
527 uh represent spillsbury you're
you're the maker of 739 can you explain
a little
bit yes so 739 as I said during the
hearing was an effort to approach the
swept the excess swept issue as narrowly
and surgically as possible uh one way or
another of dealing with swept has been
Ed in uh probably a half dozen of our
bills um and I just have to say it again
I'm I'm going to urge that we pass this
but I'm not a fan of swept and uh and I
am sympathetic to the so-called donor
towns um I would love it if we come up
with an entirely different uh approach
but in the mean time we've got the
pening court decision and we've got our
own sense that this isn't uh um
it's not structured correctly so uh I
think the money is there and uh as much
as I hate to squeeze it out of a few
towns um we can use it in other
ways any further discussion represent
luno sure thanks very much Mr chair um
yeah I I I think moving forward with
with with um with
739 um uh makes sense I actually I I
very much appreciate and and like the
policy in
734 uh as it relates to swep because it
gets rid of that sort of donor you know
concept of if you've got excess you send
it to the Dr 7 734 would have you know
you you you collect it locally and send
it all in um just like how other state
taxes are collected whether it's
business profits taxes you just you send
it all in you don't you don't keep you
don't retain um some of it so but um but
I think 739 is a good um a good vehicle
on this my my question would be though
just to um with we we've got we've got
Mark and Bruce here just to make sure
that the Dr has everything they need in
this legislation so that they can um uh
so that they can carry out that process
and that um the uh the legisl the bill
also has the necessary language to
um I guess as far as anything that's
needed by the department of Ed so so at
this time maybe what we could do is
invite Dr up if if there's anything they
see in
730 what 303
7:34 in 7:39 7:39 yes 739 yes
yes
that that isn't going to work or is
good morning good morning chairman lad
members of the committee uh Bruce caner
supervisor Municipal Bureau
um I did it again
SL sound check there we go that sounds
good Bruce okay again good morning
chairman lad members of the committee my
name is Bruce canu supervisor of the
municipal Bureau of Department of
739 I think that the analyst had noted
just a small question about now this is
not my forte on the analysis section of
a bill but it's it mentioned being
deposited into the general fund and I
think the legislation called for as it
would be uh Dr depositing it with the
treasury for the education trust
fund
um is that correct other than that um
didn't have any technical issues that I
I
saw go ahead yeah so where where is that
that technical correction it say right
on the analysis right on the if I can if
I can point to um
line
2829 what this says is uh and pay it to
the Department of Revenue Administration
for deposit in the education trust fund
right yeah right it was just it was a
note that somebody said the analysis
language said general fund that's it
says right here in the analysis that's
not that's not part of the law that's
right okay so I said I think I think
that would be a good thing to address in
the committee report
okay yeah oh the the the not the LBA
analysis the the top yeah right yeah the
very top
yeah yeah just it's just incorrect that
yeah but that's not the law though the
law and thank you cuz I hadn't noticed
it but we can address that very
concisely that can be correct y yeah
technical stuff anything further yes
represent McGuire thank you Mr chairman
so one criticism I've heard of this bill
is that the word excess is not defined
in the law anywhere is that true and but
it's sort of understood by the Dr what
it
means it is understood by Dr what for
what it it means I think that's probably
because we knew what it meant in in the
past when the legislation was there and
then
stricken um I'm not sure if if Mark who
I know is behind me Mark do you have a
discussion we're talking about excess
definition of excess yeah it's funny you
read these bills and you know exactly
what they're trying to do so you kind of
read between the lines as far as what
what's there but yeah Clarity could be
you could you could add a definition to
clarify that um at this moment in time I
I might um as things go to D2 I would
read through things more more carefully
as the as the bills get closer to the
Finish Line to see if there's any Tech
issues but at this moment in time I
think um both departments would
interpret it to mean exactly what we all
think however if you're concerned about
future legal litigation being clear um
doesn't hurt anyone so you're going to
kick the can down to Maguire at B2 and
let them do it you could you could you
Define excess and be very you could say
you could add an amendment that says
excess shall be the difference
between um the difference between the
cost of inadequate education and the SW
swept warrant for that so for the record
I think the interpretation question is
pretty well settled by the fact that
this restores prior
law yeah yeah
it um it's it's understood what it means
but if you want to add Clarity there you
could you could make an amendment to do
that further
discussion yes repes
fellows so I it's not clear to
me when when Dr is is is Dr supposed to
tell them what the excess is that they
need to remit because I'm thinking you
don't know how much the excess is until
you do the final calculation of adequacy
Aid and so the department would of
Education would need to tell Dr how much
is the excess and that's right up close
to when they're setting the tax rates so
timing representative oh yes um Dr would
need to know you have to speak into the
mic sorry now I can hear myself
yes I will get used to this one of these
times yes the ra would need to know the
amount of the excess quote unquote in
order to place that amount onto the
respective
warrant I think so follow up yes so the
warrant the currently the warrant that
Dr sends to the school districts is way
before that it's is you know more than a
year
before the actual excess is even
determined so are they supposed to do
two
warrants
no as it would have been done when it
was
done we would at
Dr calculate the amount of State
municipality and at the same time alert
that education to that so again I let's
look at this in
retrospect the the warrants that were
issued last
1 would have
needed work by education to say with
such a swept amount for a
municipality we need you to tell us with
that how much of it would exceed the the
fiscal of the financial aid the adequacy
aid then come back to us and say of that
amount this amount is quote excess and
then the warrant would have the language
of the old warrants it would include
that statement that the as calculated
per statute the excess amount of X is to
be uh forwarded to I don't remember the
exact language although I do have an
example with me here today if I need to
so the timing would be a back and forth
somewhere between it could be anywhere
between say June and October
1st so I think what and so and I think I
know what representative fellow is
talking about she's talking about the
instability in the ADM data is that what
you're referring
to instability the ADM data between
October and
April so well yes because you you're
doing the department puts out a
preliminary at which is an estimate of
what adequacy 8 is going to be for tax
setting right so that so that um they
can you know towns can vote on their
budget knowing about how much they're
going to get but the actual excess you
don't know until
November right so it would be um there'
be the budgeting process where no taxes
have been levied it's all just uh
theoretical for budgeting that's the
first adequacy estimate and that
estimate uh can be off by quite a bit
because it's forecasting
ADM um then once tax season starts it
would be known once we collected the
prior your ADM data it is known in
September 1st after we've processed the
data what is your adequacy going to be
to that fisal year at that moment in
time uh towns would know with um uh very
very good certainty as far as what their
excess swep payment is going to be we do
that first September 1st calculation
then we do an October 1st calculation
for Dr so that we say we've given this
out we've given out the assessment
September 1st now we're happy for you to
set taxes off this number because we're
very confident in it but there's still
issues where ADM data can change now the
governor has introduced language um um
that freezes ADM data so they can't be
any movement in ADM data um this is an
hb2 um which I know is not in this
committee it's in finance but it freezes
ADM data so once taxes are set an ADM is
determined uh EXs swept is determined it
cannot change without a petition to the
State Board of Education that's language
in hb2 so that would solve any minor
tinkering in the data after October 1st
HB there's language in hb2 To address
that but essentially we know what excess
swept is September 1st of a fiscal year
available so so well we don't know
what's going to happen with hb2 we don't
know if that'll be because that's
certainly concerning that um it that
there would be a law that says we don't
care if if the numbers are right or
wrong we're just going to use whatever
you gave us what
whatever some whatever it was calculated
which could have been a mistake on the
part of the um School District or it
could have been a mistake on the part of
the Department of Education we're going
to use it anyway yeah the hp2 language
has a a petition process for if
something does need to be rectified um
it has to be um go through a public
process instead of data sharing the
normal data sharing process between U
the department and the uh District Mr
chair yes represent luno thank you very
much so so to to representive fellow's
question though if the if the if the
language instead was rather than
remitting the excess all of it was
collected locally all of it was remitted
to the to the Dr and uh and then the
department calculated the adequacy Grant
and that money was was transferred back
to the municipalities that would um um I
mean I think your answer to it the the
timing was was good anyway worked anyway
but but that collecting it all remitting
it all would also um you know is also a
right yes representative luno it's a
different solution and it causes Dr to
act differently if there is no excess to
be mentioned then we'll just
calculate the
municipalities state educ property tax
and it would be collected through the
normal tax billing process the the
payments is some would be something new
and that that's the that's the need for
some work on the revenue um system at Dr
okay in the past that didn't exist so
obviously it came in literally through
the mail M um
but so
okay I I think that there's two ways of
doing this right and and they both would
work I want to go on right now if we can
to the last portion on this this block
of bills it's HP 527 that's represent
fellow's
please um so what is the intent here
because it says to remit the excess but
is that the are you just putting a tax
on the town or are you really expecting
them to admit to um remit what was
not remit the amount that was actually
collected from that tax because we know
not everybody pays their property tax
that thanks for that question
representative fellows I don't know the
answer to how Dr I can't speak for the
agency on that matter as
to again I'm drawing on
History um it was expected here's what a
warrant sounded
like in November of 2000 I'll leave the
town out in accordance with the
provisions of RSA 763 as an enacted on
November 3rd 1999 under chapter 338 laws
of
1999 you are hereby required to assess
the sum of
3,477
1898 for the 2001 State education
property tax the amount above includes
excess property taxes of $
61,7
73 per RSA 198 col 46 this excess
education property tax payment is
payable to the state of New Hampshire
honor before March 15
2002 such payment should be forwarded to
and then the prior address of of Dr over
on Chanel
drive so the expectation was that the
town would collect the taxes as
everybody knows sometimes individual
property taxes are not
collected the amount to be remitted is
still
expected the towns have the authority to
lean property taxes that are not paid
and unfortunately sometimes in the event
of successive non-payment tax deeding
process would
occur but the expectation is you've been
ordered to pay that
amount now I can't speak for the history
obviously and none of us have practiced
this for a long long time so I don't
have a spefic specific answer as to what
would happen in this case it's not an
individual taxpayer you're talking about
the
municipality represent spillsbury do you
have some yeah in an effort to clarify
what is the magnitude of this concern
which I think is the towns might get
squeezed if they don't have sufficient
cash flow because they haven't collected
all if we went back to the um process
the alternative um in
734 of having every community remit all
of their swept than to have the Dr
reconcile pardon me and distribute
adequacy Aid that would compound your
concern dramatically because now instead
of a few towns sending only the excess
every town would have to send all of it
uh so you know this if anything
minimizes your concern and I'm going to
guess that a community that is remitting
the excess has adequate reserves um from
what they've otherwise collected I think
another
incidental advantage of leaving uh the
communities to collect and retain what
they're you know the amount that they're
then do inadequacy is it gives them cash
flow protection it probably helps cash
management and avoid uh um tax
anticipation notes and so
on yes representative papich just in an
effort to fully address the concerns of
my colleague because I understand there
are significant concerns I've been the
town finance director for the town of
wiam for six years and a half before
serving here we dealt with those
situations all the time and for the
record the town of wiam has the smallest
reserve of funds in the state by mile if
you ask the Dr when they graph
everybody's here and we are faring our
corner corner all by ourselves we were
at 300,000 reserves when I was the
finance director and we manag fine the
there are few people generally who don't
pay prop property taxes if it's a
recurring problem where lots of people
don't pay there are interest costs
attached there is tax diding processes
so towns who have those issues know how
to manage them they they are a headache
to the finance director but they really
shouldn't be a headache to us because
the towns have proven themselves over
time to be very capable at managing that
and at a point if you have incurring
losses on that again there are ways to
mitigate it you increase the budget by a
little bit to accommodate those losses
so for the purposes of this committee I
want assure you my professional opinion
is that it really shouldn't be something
that weighs heavily on our minds we
should focus on much bigger concerns
over the you know fairness of this and
so on and so forth thank you okay one
last
question so well it's not a question
this is a work session can I just say
what I think you sure go ahead so I I
think if you have a Statewide tax then
it's the
state that should um not get Revenue
that's not paid for that tax and it
should not be the obligation of the town
to make that payment on behalf of the
taxpayer if we're talking about a state
tax and the second thing I'd like to say
is that I
oppose the entire idea of there being a
state property tax
because
municipalities have only one significant
source of Revenue and that's the
property tax if we let the state
encroach on that source of
Revenue then where does it stop you know
it can't you know right now the amount
might be somewhat
manageable but if the state increases
this if if if it's legitimate for the
state to have a property tax then it's
legitimate for the state to increase
that property tax and so where do you
stop do you double it do you triple it
and then you can use that to pay for all
of the cost of education is that the
point of all the lawsuits that we've
heard no of course not so I will not
support this Bill thank you represent
spillsbury uh I don't think I'm going to
be able to persuade you otherwise but I
would just say that the purpose of this
bill is that until there is some
alternative this bill is
necessary any further discussion from
the committee on this block of three
bills okay so what we're going to do is
we're going to take a brief caucus and
then we're going to come back the idea
that we want to look at is to retain 734
as we discussed move 739 forward as it
is and itl 527
discuss would you like to discuss it
further go
ahead I just I you can accept the
statement that I just made as part of my
um support for this bill but in addition
to that this particular bill is revenue
neutral it makes no change to any any
the amount that any District would get
in terms of adequacy Aid Grant from the
state it just
takes off the
um for one thing it it's trans it's it
creates
transparency because it does we do not
say we would not be saying anymore that
we have a state property tax because
most of the public thinks there really
is a state property tax and the money is
case
and I think it gives
us it it it makes the um adequacy Aid
more transparent and and and there's it
just re basically reflects what we are
doing right now and it gives us
opportunity to work with that local
Revenue
contribution you know maybe change the
formula for
that okay any further discussion on on
these bills so we're going to go into a
f minute caucus come back and and we'll
action
e
okay welcome back everybody so we have
these three bills in front of us uh
we're going to be uh uh entertaining a
motion here uh representative kcom on HB
734 would you please make a
motion HB 734 I'd like to motion that we
retain that please is there a second
I'll second that okay we have a motion
made by R and kcom to retain this is uh
relative to the State education property
tax and the low and moderate income
homeowners property tax relief program
and it's been second by represent luno
uh represent kcom do you have do you
care to speak to it no I think we can
move on okay represent luno so thanks
thanks very much um yeah I'm I'm I'm
happy that we're retaining this I think
this does do U comprehensive um
Statewide education property tax reform
and couples it with a low and moderate
property tax relief program uh um to
benefit people that live in communities
all across the state so so I support
this motion thank you very much
represent spillsbury do you have a yeah
I I have had the pleasure of sitting on
Ways and Means with representative Ames
the last two terms and we've seen this
bill before and I don't think that the
provisions on uh the low and moderate
income credit ever really got their due
so I'm very much in support of rain yeah
I I I did owe that okay further
discussion on that we have have a motion
to uh retain uh HB
734 any further
discussion not seeing any further
discussion Madam clerk would you please
take the
role Vice chairman bills bearing
yes representative Maguire
absent representative Earth yes
representative kopal yes representative
kcom yes bovich yes representative Brown
yes representative
mahagan yes representative peoples yes
representative luno yes representative
Ames yes representative Burton yes
representative fellows yes
representative Dame Damon sorry yes
representative bricky yes representative
Gran yes representative Weinstein yes
German lad
yes 17 yay zero nay and one absent thank
you very much Madam
clerk okay the next bill which we're
going to be dealing with is HP 527
replacing the Statewide education
property tax for the local Revenue
contribution I Look to representative
papovich for a motion please thank you
Mr chair I I will make a motion of ital
for HB 527 is there a second I'll second
that represent makes that second
representa papovich would you like to
speak to your motion I will be very
brief and say that um even though the
intent of the bill is well met
um it seems that the majority of the
committee feels that this is not an
appropriate vehicle to move forward and
therefore it should be ideal thank you
thank you represent luno thank you we're
good any further discussion from the
committee not seeing any U Madam clerk
when you're ready we're ready Vice
chairman spills baring
yes representative Maguire is absent
representative F yes representative
kofalt yes representative kcom yes
representative Popovich yes
representative Brown yes representative
mahagan yes representative peoples yes
representative luno yes representative
Ames yes representative Burton yes
representative fellows
no representative Damon yes
Representative bricking
no representative kitan
yes representative Weinstein yes
chairman lad
yes so 15 yay two no and one absent yeah
well just is 152 okay okay um chair
pardon me I I I don't know whether this
uh you know we'll go on the consent or
not uh not consent okay we we'll keep it
off are you writing a minority repor
okay and there'll be a majority report
thank you very much
me uh see um this will I I need this
today is what Tuesday how about by
Thursday email it to you that's fine
just send it my email
address um the next bill which we have
is
739 and we're going to hold on this bill
and and take action on it in March four
I'm going to ask that both represent
luno and representative spillsbury get
together with Bruce and Mark uh and and
talk about this issue of the dates for
the warrant and see if that something
can be worked out both of you please Mr
chair yes if I may did you just say
Thursday for the committee reports
because I I'm not sure I thought the
Wednesday well if if we're we're going
to go there that would be the
March March because we have a session
next week I didn't
know yeah there is there is a session
next week yes Wednesday so okay get it
in by when by noon time Wednesday by
noon time Wednesday thank you I'll have
it mine today appreciate herim papovich
uh we're right now at about 8 minutes of
uh 12 and I I there's a next group of
five bills all coupled together I'd like
to come back after lunch to do those I
think we're all a little wiped out here
um it's Ty and all
time uh so at any rate we'll come back
and this maybe gives uh represent luno
and and represent SP a second to talk to
Bruce and Mark while they're right here
uh regarding that last bill which we did
trying to get the that the the warrant
date Square time squared
away thank
you we'll break and we'll come back at 1
o'
you
e
okay we're going to go ahead with this
afternoon's
bills uh what I'm going to try to do
here quickly if we can just get rid of
one of these bills first and because
it's the bill that deals with the um
community college system in the in the
higher education University system um
I'd like to jump down and take 510
quickly and we have received
information uh from from uh folks that
work at the higher education
institutions and regarding their code of
ethics and numerous issues which we had
not had a chance to look at um and this
bill uh comes to us and I I just my my
gut is I don't think we're ready to go
anywhere with it yet there's a lot of
work that has to be done on this process
I'd like to see a retention
motion and so you're you're the you're
here from the level punch come on up and
or
unless did Chad drive all the way up
from
okay yeah it's the last one on the
are there any people here on the
committee which would object to a
retention on this bill that's 510 the
last
co-sponsor I expect you to go anywh you
want to go vote your conscience in that
else so we we know where we're going to
go on that pardon
me yes per I just I just repeat that
it's um I did I'm sorry um I have all of
the D process within the university
system and they're very strong I don't
see the need to we we saw that other
stuff that Shannon sent us as well and
this is from the University too that
yeah I I I I get that uh and there
there's so much information received
with everything going on I haven't had
time to read through it all and I like
to
and represent suppos right at the end of
last week's um session representative
lad and uh representative Pap Muller and
I um met with representatives for both
systems and asked for information we've
gotten a massive amount within the last
week has not yet been shared with the
committee and I think it more than
justifies a retain and maybe a
subcommittee to digest it all okay well
I can I say my my opinion is that the
whole principle having the legislature
right internal policies for the public
high edit system is a really bad
practice to follow um and and and and
that may result slippery slope of of a
subcommittee uh that's that's looking at
this uh and and and as a retained bill
it may be that that committee sees that
and makes that
recommendation that it's a slippery
slope
yeah yeah so if we're going to go that
way we can dispose of this bill right
now if everybody's good with
that okay would you please somebody make
a motion here to
retain representative McGuire yeah I'll
move to retain and is there a second
second okay so representative McGuire
second by Rend spillsbury to retain 510
further discussion from the
maker well I I do think there's this is
an important bill but it's complicated
and uh it's not as urgent as as our
other stuff right so retain seems
right yeah it's not imperative that be
done
today um any further
discussion so Madam clerk you can call
Chad
up Vice chairman spills bearing yay
representative Maguire yes
representative Earth yes representative
kofalt yes representative kcom yes
Representative poic
no representative Brown yes
representative
mahagan yes representative peoples yes
representative luno yes representative
Ames yes representative Burton
no representative fellows yes
bricky representative
Bicky not
here representative cran she can't vote
because she's not here okay
representative cran you have
to
yes representative Weinstein yes
chairman lad yes okay so it's retained
so 15 yes two no and one absent
okay okay uh then we'll jump back up
into the other group now HP 550 563 651
769 and
772 that last one there 675 I'm holding
separately uh I did pass out information
this is just basically the funding
formula we're going to have to look at
and I just just like to um in regard to
I'm going to look at 563 here first
seeing that has some of these components
it okay 563 has those components and the
first component that we in the costing
areas is your base cost and on line
seven of 563 it identifies
4266 as the base cost for
Education everybody should have in front
here okay this sheet reflects the
formula
used back in 2008 but then updated it uh
to 42 uh on on the front side where it
says features and the First Column and
going across you'll see one two three
over where there's a sum of uh uh uh
$425 that is of those that are beginning
teachers are starting this is the
average of those salaries as developed
by our Our People
upstairs and from the doe website so
it's
$425 with with a
33% increase due to benefits you can see
that that that starting teacher would be
around
5665 we have some teachers starting in
the state at
$31,000 and some at60 something th000
it's it's way off the charts in terms
whether you're from Hanover or you're
some some poor
Community the same thing is done all the
way down through the uh those
individuals which were in in uh area
such as instructional materials
technology Etc that was used to
determine what are the costs of a uh of
the base cost for Education back in 2008
use the same formula and it comes out
with the changes and updating them and
it's not perfect I'll be the first one
to admit that and it may not include all
the things which you may see as a need
under 193 e2a but these are the same
components
that were part of the formula back then
so they are the same components right
now that are right before you here it
comes out the $4,260
going on
down the differentiated Aid has three
categories as you know free and reduced
meals English language learner and
special education services they're
estimated at the by the Department of
Education to be in your spreadsheets for
the area of free and reduce meals at
$2,393 that's what they have estimated
we just take the figures and put it
right in
here for the English language learner
the same thing occurred there uh it was
800 by taking your 2% increase or
whatever it is um it comes out to 832
and that's what's been estimated by
department on the other side though down
below that you can see that there's a
cost in the
part C below that that this all would be
changed and this have to be amended to
include a category which Deals Only with
um special education differentiated
Aid that takes you to that second sheet
here did you get a copy of
this it should be staple two staple two
yes
you have the color no that's right um my
absent house has it um on that sheet
right there it looks at differentiated
Aid as it could be calculated and the
current projected cost would be
$2,185 this projects a cost out at
$3,078 how do we arrive at that the 13
category areas from autism down to
through disabilities and emotional
handicap and and multiple disabilities
and jumping down through speech and
speech language and traumatic brain
injury visually impaired you can see
that the case loads vary amongst which
IEPs you can see that a speech language
uh teacher can have as many as
48 kids to one on their case loads you
look at Asha and that's what they show
you is the max American speech and
hearing
Association um but then you look at some
of the other categories it's much much
lower because of the time that requires
to support those students it's not
perfect but it's another way of looking
at this so that then we take the number
of students and we know that there are
are are um
13,469 IEP students in our state
breaking them down
you can see how many are in each speech
language you can see there's 10,235 kids
there in that one category so they add
up to that that
total then when you divide it by the
case load you can see how many teachers
you would need Statewide autism it' be
311 in that category what we're trying
to arrive at is what is the cost for uh
autism you can see it's the cost is 20
million plus dollars it's different for
all the 13 categories as you go down
seeing that some total would be $98
million using this we currently fund uh
the education different differentiated
Aid at $68.7 million this formula
increases more money for special
education if you were to take and divide
by the number of
kids which we will have in FY 26 it's on
the bottom part there uh because there's
two numbers we used in this one was from
FY 23 on were projected for FY 26 down
FY 26 it would come out to
$3,078 per average case load average
case load and that would be an increase
of $28
million if we if we did something like
this or we could just leave it the way
it
is um going across the formula further
to the right you come across out of the
the areas on the left hand side of the
formula again are non-targeted monies
they all couple into this pot of money
which the school district gets base cost
and the three differentiated a
categories that's totaled up and that is
nontargeted money which Goes to School
District on the right hand side of the
formula find extraordinary needs Grant
which is targeted money it's a grant and
you also have a column we call hold
harmless it's not here on any sheet you
have in front of you you may have it on
a
spreadsheet and so this proposal right
here proposes that and it was using the
$28 million that came from the SWAT but
we're finding now that there's some
issues with that seeing that the warrant
articles and all that timing are already
being done and that would all have to be
changed so this the part where the
differentiator would probably start in
FY 27 FY 26 would remain uh as it's
proposed there that's basically it we
have some other options though available
to us how to use the extraordinary needs
money that's $184 million and they hold
harmless roughly another $50 million
adding the two together you have $250
million of which then you can start
taking instead of using extraordinary
needs which is based upon equalized
property valuation per pupil multiplied
by the number of free and reduced in
that District to get that money we have
other ways fiscal capacity which deals
with equalized value a property
valuation and all students in the
municipality so there's an income way
that you know and and and and the we
called it free and relief once um
there's several ways so this is really
open and and it's open for discussion
right now what route we take and what
route given our revenues we can afford
to
take y yeah repr luno thanks very much
Mr chair and thanks for um for
introducing um um 563 again to us and um
and you know there's a lot of there's a
lot of dials you can turn yeah um on
this and I think um representative lad
has identified uh the special education
dial when it comes to the um calculation
of the cost of inadequate education I
think that's appropriate uh
it would be great if we could um
increase the differentiate Factor by an
additional $28 million starting with the
first year in the in the 2627 budget but
I think um given what what uh what we
learned this morning with some timing uh
of some things I think introducing it
for FY 27 makes a lot of sense uh when
the availability of $28 million um might
be there uh through the uh the excess
weep uh coming back to the education
trust fund um but um I'll tell you what
what I'm what I'm very interested about
interested in is um is is looking to to
evolve the extraordinary needs Grant
from you know this this complicated
connection of of um of access to
resources which is the equalized
valuation and the the additional costs
that that districts bear when when
educating kids students from lwi income
backgrounds rather than combining those
into a single factor is really to treat
those two factors uh independently and
access to resources if you don't have
access to resources it's hard to put on
a program to begin with you don't need
to make it more difficult by by adding
another Factor onto it um so by breaking
it into the two into individual
components fiscal capacity disparity
Grant free introduced price lunch Grant
I think makes a lot of sense and I think
if we could take the the um the
approximately 134 $140
million um I'm sorry $240 million uh
that are currently comprise the
extraordinary needs Grant plus the hold
harmless and uh split that between
fiscal capacity disparity and uh and a
uh a loow income uh uh Grant based on
the number of kids in the free and
reduced price launch program uh I think
that makes a lot of sense and uh and you
know to be to be spoton on the numbers
maybe um maybe a place to look at would
be U 184 million um going to fiscal
capacity disparity and 50 million uh to
the uh the enhanced free and reduced
price lunch uh lowi income Grant uh and
that would um that would
I that that would essentially I think
use the the um the the monies that are
presently allocated to extraordinary
needs and the whole harmless but but I'd
want to see how that how that models out
and and how that affects um cities and
towns around the state because one of
the things the extraordinary needs Grant
did when it came into play two years ago
uh is um is is replace the stabilization
grant that had been been there for um uh
a decade or more I
think come on back unfortunately I have
to leave briefly for another committee
but uh I very strongly endorse the the
comments that you just made
representative luno and i' I'd like to
see those numbers as well okay great
thank so going a little further uh
represent F you you've worked with you
know the people across the
street and and we're hearing that we
have we know we have $184 million
extraordinary needs and then we have
harmless and I just heard represent luno
say okay let's put a weighted amount in
the fiscal capacity and have the smaller
amount roughly 4750
million go go into the fnr side have you
done any kind of spread sheaks like this
and how's that how's that challenge Us
in terms of trying to put a budget
together the short answer is no but can
I ask representative luno a question
sure so I understood the put all the
extraordinary needs into the disparity
what was the second part the 50 million
part oh was was from the hold harmless
and it would go into I know that but
into what into into a a a grant tied to
the number of of of students from
lowincome amilies that uh that that are
in a district and um based on fnr or
something else well no based on fnr
because that's how we how we identify
okay the number of these kids right now
and it's exactly the same factor we use
in the left side of the formula with in
the adequacy calculation but this would
be a a um uh this would be a you know
right half of the formula rant um but is
it the extraordinary needs just limited
to 50 million or more narrowly targeted
or is it another calculation no no it's
it's it's basically it's the it's the
it's the it's the two it's replacing the
two grants that are in there right now
the extraordinary needs and the whole
hold harmless um and wait wait can I
explain it to you what what he's trying
to do we have the extraordinary needs
what we want to do is put that into the
fiscal capacity disparity I got that
part okay the other part the hold heart
would go into a called relief Aid or
Relief Fund and that's staying on the
right hand side and it's it's allocated
based upon the fnr formula we have which
fnr formula that we have the
extraordinary needs one the one that's
on the left hand side no no no just
sheer the the student count number of
students the percent so take the 50
million or whatever it is divide by the
total number of students in the state
and then allocate it that way y yeah
per per District per student per
District yeah but wouldn't that just be
addition in addition to the left side
numbers um yeah I mean it it would but
it stays on the right side because it's
not calculated as as um okay it's part
of the adequacy form okay so back to my
original answer it's still no I hadn't
actually model that but but you're right
it would be supplemental to to that got
it so okay I can't speak directly that
although you probably have an idea what
that does since you've got on the left
that already but I can speak to the
other um essentially
substituting the fiscal capacity
disparity at approach to the
extraordinary needs approach um and well
I'm not going to debate the merits of
either one but the the problem is
switching like that you'll jumble
everything up and you'll have some towns
going way up you know some towns going
way down you know some towns you know
that's why I think it's worth modeling
it's worth taking a look at what how
that calculation okay let me just tell
you something else another approach that
I considered in the hopes of not Bing
things up completely and it still might
create a problem for my other hat when
I'm in finance but putting that aside
for the moment um rather than trying to
totally upend the extraordinary needs
model um but moving towards the fiscal
capacity disparity model
uh I I model so it the the the change
that we made last by Anum really
dramatically impacted
negatively Five Towns so what I did was
model specifically targeting
money towards those five towns this like
Charles toown Berlin
Claremont the other two are escaping off
top my head right now but I can look
them up um and so that's one piece and
the other part of that was specifically
targeting the largest
District uh capping it negatively so
that's Manchester going down um I'm sure
you're this committee is probably pretty
aware that the changes you made last
bium rocketed Manchester's uh adequacy
way up um to the detriment of many other
towns across the state gred does that
kind of answer your question as far as I
can go with
it repres Luna or should I talk to Mr
chairman so my question then by doing
the form me that you're indicating one
last thing so the impact of that overall
yeah is an increase over the banum okay
of $55 million and that does not include
not doing the sped increase in the first
uh year as you I think we're just
discussing here this the left side sped
increase which I think you were
discussing here if I if I heard things
yeah so you're indicating then that for
FY 27 it would be that 50 million
increase there you plus the 28 if we no
no the $55 million is over the
banum okay and it includes the special
education increase you were talking
about for both years and then this other
thing I described the other two things I
described for one year the last the 20
27 year does that make sense I'm not
following the for both years because I
think I didn't get can you say that
again please yeah so let's just talk
about the left side first yes
[Music]
that why don't you go further and ask a
little bit more about what you're trying
to drive at I'm trying to follow the
discussion so are we looking at the
current adequacy Aid in discussing
changes to
that based on right now it seems to be
some kind of discussion about
extraordinary grants versus yes so
there's versus two things was it there's
extraordinary needs Grant and that's on
the those are grants on the right hand
side of the formula they total $184
million on the left hand side we have
what we call the adequacy understand yes
okay so what we're talking about what
are we going to do are we going to keep
the extraordinary needs Grant monies
intact the way they are right now based
upon that formula or are we going to try
to Target those monies those are
targeted Monies to better support some
of those property poor towns so so does
that mean we're looking at the you know
like I've got the column here
extraordinary 800 1884 million and the
the two options we're kind of looking at
keeping it the way it is or doing
something that instead of dividing it by
free and reduced just dividing it by
regular student count ADM okay okay so
there's really three
options okay on the right side but
before I get to that let me just clarify
the left side because some of my totals
include the whole package so let me just
clarify what happened on the left side
and then I'll move to the right side so
on the left side chairman lad described
increasing the per pupil per student per
special education student by about
$884 okay so and I think I just heard it
just correct me if I'm wrong to
represent a lab but I thought somebody
you you indicated that we could not
apply that in the first year because of
problems with the whole thing with Dr
and all that is that yeah that's what I
understand our conversation just for
lunch I just want to be very clear yeah
okay all right so in the in the dollars
I'm going to give you I have not yet
made that subtraction in other words I
included the sped increase for both
years so that'll be a net subtraction
when we get to that point now let me
move to the right side okay now what I
heard here and representative lad will
interrupt me if I'm or chairman lad if I
State this
incorrectly the discussion Senator on
taking extraordinary needs out
completely and putting back in fiscal
disparity Aid in its place as it existed
two years
ago so that's that's what I I need to
understand what is that say that one
more time explain what that is explain
oh oh oh oh oh my
gosh um I figured you'd know better than
I since you've been on here um do you
know the actual details of the formula
sure I mean I mean I can I can I can
speak to the extraordinary needs Grant
oh sure sure so fiscal capacity
disparity Grant would would would
basically start with with a um it's it's
to cities and towns based on their
equalized property value per pupil okay
so so and it would it would at its
highest point be go the highest Grant
amount per pupil uh would go to go to
the towns with the lowest equalized
property value per pupil and then that
would taper to zero um over over some
range and the range I I think that
representative lad and I have used in
the past take you to right around the
state average equalized property value
per pupil is that right represent Medi
yeah Medi yeah the the yeah yeah median
not the not the average median and um
and um and then um and and and basically
the the the amount the the grant amount
for each one of those slivers uh would
be uh you know obviously defined by the
area that um of of that of that of that
line and and U Mickey will easily
calculate that first so I understand
when now that you explain it I remember
what what it looks like it's got It's it
hits a bottom level and it hits a top
level and it slides per pup in the
middle and there's no Cliff do you
remember what the total cost of that was
we can set the total cost to be whatever
we want it to be right just well what
was it two years
ago I can't remember less than 184
million I would contend yeah well the
the hund so so two years ago to be clear
the the 184 million didn't replace
fiscal capacity disparity replace
stabilization
you know the history better than I do at
some point FAL capacity was in there and
around3 that was years ago no that was
two years ago okay well they stole from
they stole from the left but it was set
many years ago it was set it was set
many years ago but it was replaced two
years ago correct in the um in the in
the budget but but understand this
fiscal capacity disparity as he just
described is based on something as
opposed to stabilization all that they
were they were sort of constants that
were scrapped out so if you understand
physical capacity disparity Aid you got
that okay all I want to say is I did not
I I have modeled that one for one
between extraordinary needs versus
physical capacity disparity Aid and it
it totally flips all kinds of things I
don't mean flips like but like
everything and as soon as you do that
some towns are
dramatically reduced some towns are
dramatically increased and as I
understand again this is just my
understanding from all past years with
you all U is that you don't generally
want to have negative amounts going out
to towns so I can model what you just
asked for and I would glad to have that
done but what I did model was something
that I was an attempt to not have it
Tipsy Topsy everything and yet address
the big problem which was those towns
who were most
dramatically impacted negatively when
physical capacity went away or if it
comes back and the towns I was targeting
were the and so instead of the um notion
of you know going from the median down I
went specifically to the bottom Five
Towns okay which I can which we can do
by the just by adjusting what the cut
offs are in the in the in the in the
figures in the amounts and in doing that
just targeting those towns and at the
same time another change that well not
another change the change that was made
regarding the extraordinary needs Grant
two years ago
dramatically
increased Manchester and Nash and I
think a couple other cities but really
Manchester a lot and so cap that Capp
what they got so reduced it what they
got going forward by about $10 million
roughly $12 million maybe um to count to
help offset the the changes I just
described to fiscal capacity of
good so what are you telling me about
the five towns what happens to them
they're the ones who got the big the
fiscal capacity disparity Aid was
applied to them they go down and they go
up they go down they go
up they get more money and
extraordinary no the extraordinary is
still there extraordinary is not not in
in the model I described I did not want
to take extraordinary away because it
would so so grossly change everything
else so the idea was hold every other
Town constant except for Manchester
which went down and these five towns
that went
up okay does that make sense yeah so so
you're adding you're adding in
essentially the fiscal capacity to Five
Towns just making a new column oh fiscal
capacity only for Five Towns
yes did you look at the per pupil amount
when you made these changes this this
isn't not per pupil this is on the right
side I'm asking you did did you look at
scenarios I guess I'm not quite sure in
what context you're asking that this was
targeted Aid
right anyway do you understand this what
I did um
so okay so you're you're only changing
Five
Towns six and Manchester make six oh six
okay okay now let me just finish let me
just finish okay so the impact of that
was as follows this is what I wanted to
get to the increase total increase of
the formula over the two years it's
about $55
million and as I said at the very
beginning that does not exclude applying
the extra funding of special education
on the Le hand side in the first year
okay so that's all I wanted to say and
anything else can be modeled as well
that was just what the approach I
took so we just tried so $55 million
over the
banum to to impact six
towns no no no and all the special
education on the left hand side as
well oh the increases per pupil on the
left-and side for special education for
both years
okay that was $884 roughly I think
chairman lad mentioned per student in
each of the yeah so how much was his
special ed that was I I I can't break it
down to my I think he said $28 million
was it the amount that we're allocating
for special education the
extra no I think she wants in total
don't you was it oh oh the total cost
was uh
million oh additional cost 28.1 million
for both years or one year that's for
one year so double that then so
something's not quite right with his
map he's in education what can I
say 28.1 yeah but currently we're
spending 68.7 million per year
this would increase to
96 whoa whoa whoa whoa Hy hang on hang
on hang on um all my numbers are with
respect to the governor's budget since
that's what we're working off of I think
he's looking
at projections from last year or
something so when you say special ed are
you talking about catastrophic
or okay I'm just talking about the
governor's everything all my numbers
compared to so this is the governor's
budget adequacy line if you go into the
budget you'll see that line in there
paper so in the governor's budget it's
one this is FY FY 26
1.08 billion doll for the first year and
$ 1.08 billion for the second
year right so the the numbers for what I
just tried to describe to you
1.17 billion for the first year and 1.11
year and if we left and if we left the
extraordinary needs Grant as it
is and we also had the increase for
special education differentiated Aid
which is the amount of
$3,078 per kid raising that line item up
to 96.8 million the cost would be $1.07
N9
billion so it's pretty
close um quick quick quick question
represent on that explanation so so what
you just talked about was for um for the
two years FY 26 and FY 27 and um so uh
and I just want to clarify for for
particularly FY 26 but but looking for
both years too particularly for FY
26 where um where we've got um school
districts in the next number of weeks
voting on budgets for their FY 26 that
that none of the the districts would be
receiving less money from the state than
what has already been estimated in the
in the current under current law is that
correct so the changes I described did
not affect the first year at all okay
it's exactly what it was the only
difference was it did have additional
monies for the special education
addition money yeah I want to make sure
that nobody's getting less than what
they built their budgets around and
unless the formulas you guys already had
made it go down I that I can't speak but
I I did not change it it's whatever
right right all I affected was yeah FY
okay and I'll be happy to look at this
f&r thing the the f&r thing is kind of a
result of we had a bill it was
1583 last
year and
1583 took the monies which we're talking
about the extraordinary need
monies and it broke it up amongst fiscal
capacity faity
Aid and relief
funding now relief
funding in a mun municipality which had
48% or more of their population as
fnr would get $800 per pupil then it
came down that scale to where you're at
12% or more you got 200 that's how we
split that up there and then the fiscal
capacity was done as you've
explained so that's why I thought
physical capacity was in there last last
year because you guys did it last year
and then the Senate SP that out there is
there's two different another fund there
that we weren't even talking
about so I guess what I'd like to find
out is how's that all work Dan excuse me
represent
McGuire I you can call me Dan
um in general I dislike cliffs in
formulas if you're over 800 you get X if
you're below 800 you get zero right like
this I like ramps just to be clear
everything I described is ramps I
understand but he just said no that was
ramps between 12% and 48% there was a
ramp okay up to the ceiling of 800 and
once you got to the 48% you were at that
ceiling that's all we had when you at
the floor the bottom was for you know
started at 12 200 and I think it went up
through there that it was just a ramp
okay all right good so anyways because
because then people on the edge right
you know it's it's very bad okay second
thing is we always say like it's a
phrase free and reduced do we ever say
free should be one amount and reduced
should be some other amount I mean cuz
clearly somebody who gets a free lunch
is less wealthy than somebody with a
reduced lunch yeah yeah 130% 185% but in
this one that we're just qualifying all
it's the same that's my point is
wouldn't it be better since we have I I
assume those numbers are available to
say the grant for free is slightly
bigger and the other one is is less you
know
so to be to be more Target you know more
accurately taret so I can I can tell you
about that that the reason that I think
it's that I assume it's never been
broken apart into two is because the the
reduced part is only something like
15% of the whole the vast majority of
kids who are either free and reduced is
mostly
free so where we are we're at the point
where we can look at some of those other
bills which are there chairman could I
respond to that yes so that may be true
Statewide but there might be
locations
where everyone's free and 50% are
reduced you know other ones right so
it's not like every location would have
the same split
yeah just I I would suggest if you're
interested in looking at the in incomes
of the family then you look at income
because there is census data that will
tell you by Town um median household
income and median family income and I
would suggest median as opposed to
average or obvious
reasons if that's what you want to do
really you should be using those numbers
and they have been used in the past
so thank you we still use those numbers
like that for building
and we we used those numbers back there
in the esbrook days when we looked at
fiscal capacity disparity that com that
had a double component within it medium
family income and then they look at the
quartiles and then they had the fiscal
Capac uh the the valuation of property
on the other side it was a combination
it was a blending extraordinary needs
Grant went the other way and now we're
trying to see is there of getting back
to where we can get both income and and
property there in this formula
somehow I I think yeah yeah could I
suggesting something along those lines
um you know I think it's I I think it's
certainly important to you know if we're
looking to to shift away from
extraordinary needs into you know more
more separate U type grants recognizing
the differ between fiscal capacity and
um and and students that that come from
low income uh backgrounds but but also
recognizing I think as as as
representative Earth pointed out that um
that that could create some sizable
changes for for some districts and that
we may want to take a look at I mean if
if we're going to move in a in a
direction like that talk about the the
total sum of money um which I think
we're where did we say we're
at two sorry 234
235 million between um extraordinary
needs and the hold harmless something
like that 184 plus 47 so let's let's
just just let's just pick the number
right right so so uh
31 million that we carve that up in in
three ways um two parts for the grant
and then one uh one one piece for the to
make sure that um that that districts
aren't you know getting any surprise
um I I support that you know the
weighting it heavier with the fiscal
capacity disparity a maybe 2/3 1/3
or just work the numbers that's what we
do so we're
so we're not going to have an amendment
today this oh no no no we're not going
to have an amendment we're going to have
to work an amendment out here but what
we've got to do is that um we're going
to have to decide we're going to have
one bill taking this forward right and I
would suggest we use 563 to do that and
772 that would all 772 would match up
with
734 MH I agree with
that and then the other bills then we
could just dispose of I I would I would
suggest may maybe also retaining
651 um it it's you know it it turns the
dials in the in the current Formula it
doesn't it doesn't extend beyond it I
wouldn't call it uh any sort of Reform
package or anything like that um but it
also in includes the um the the
necessary resource elements that we
talked
about essentially covers the same
characteris it it covers the same
characteristics as as we had with here
but you have some other components
within that's worth a discussion and
course also has the cost jumping from 41
to 7 it was it was really there to
illuminate um how how how just applying
one size fits-all numbers come coming
from the conval case uh how that would
how that would play out in a in a you
know in the existing one-size fits-all
funding formula I I think it'd be wiser
doing rather than I I don't mind the the
part that's down on lines 15 through 25
I think that's good stuff but
uh your other bills 772
incorporates much of this I don't know
if it has the um the well it doesn't
have the specific figures of 7 no
because it's not based on base cost
right right well it doesn't have that
and I don't think it's got the necessary
resource elements I don't remember well
that say yeah the resource elements I
have no problem with right right I do
have a problem with the 7,300 no no
I'm so but go ahead represent spillsbury
it it does seem to me that if we're
going to take action on
563 it renders this bill Moot and if we
want to uh import uh the language you
got here onlines uh 18 to 25 into 563
then okay that's an option all
right well I have a problem with
that I have a problem putting that in
the
563 because there's a lot of items
here which if you try to match it up
with what we have coming out of that
original formula they go above and
beyond yeah
okay and and then you're going to have
for example the discussion about the
nurse is the nurse part of adequacy or
not that's a conversation worth having
but it doesn't match up to what we said
before in statute comes up as an
optional service cor correct and that's
why I think you know retaining that at
least provides some I don't mind
retaining it that's all I'm suggesting
thanks so let's try to get something
done here represent McGuire on 563 are
we keeping the ABC categories going no
we're not that's going that's all going
to be that's all amended out got in fact
there's new amending language that's
already been started oh thank you very
much it's all
gone so let's look at the top here and
come through the bills here
550 modifying the base cost of
inadequate
education
that's similar to
uh that's very close to the uh other
bill you had represent
luno what's that 550 is very close to
651 651 has everything 550 has that's
exactly right so we can it 550
okay let's hear a motion somewhere
around here on this table to get rid of
550 itl I'll I'll I'll make motion to
itl 550 second okay we have a motion on
the table made by represent luno second
by represent spillsbury to itl
550 any further discussion from the
maker or the second no no no okay so
Vice Cher bills bearing yes
representative McGuire yes
representative Earth yes representative
kopal yes representative kcom yes
representative Popovich yes
representative Brown yes representative
mahagan yes representative peoples yes
representative Luna yes representative
Ames yes representative Burton yes
representative fellows yes make a motion
to representative Damon yes
representative bricky yes we just this
representative pran yes representative
Weinstein yes chairman lad yes 18 yes
done any problem with
you um yeah are you going to write the
report da two lines one line yep it'll
be couple okay
uh HB 651 I recognize uh representative
spillsbury thank you Mr chairman I move
itl on HB 651 no that's a retain retain
retain excuse
meain I I'll I'll second
that so okay so we have a motion made by
representative spilsbury second by
represent luno retain uh
651 any any discussion from the or the
second yes I truly did mean
retain okay repan luno and I truly did
mean the second retain okay thank you
ready Vice chairman spillsbury yes
representative Maguire yes
representative F yes representative
cofal yes representative kcom yes
representative Popovich yes
representative Brown yes yes
representative
mahagan yes representative peoples yes
representative Luna yes representative
ases yes representative Burton yes
representative fellows yes
representative Damon yes representative
bricking yes representative kitan yes
representative Weinstein yes and
um
thousand yeah
that's sure I recognize reference spill
spr for a motion thank you Mr chair I uh
move itl on HB 769 I'll second
that further discussion from the maker
or the second nope nope any further
discussion from the committee nope mam
ready what was the bill number again
yeah representative spills Barry yes
representative Maguire yes
representative B yes representative
kopal yes representative kcom yes
representative Popovich yes
representative Brown yes representative
mahagan
yes representative peoples yes
representative luno yes representative
Ames yes representative Burton yes
representative fellows yes
representative Damon yes representative
bricky yes representative cran yes
representative Weinstein yes chairman
lad yes 18 yes zero
no okay I'm going to hand the gavl over
to is that yeah consent any problems
with consent thank you uh I'm going to
hand the Gabel over to represent
spillsbury
thank you Mr chair so we're holding HB
563 and passing that to next week and
I'm now taking up HP
772 and I recognize uh representative
lad for a motion I'll make a motion to
retain 772 I'll second that seconded by
representative
luno any comments
no seeing no further comments um clerk
Vice T bills bearing yes representative
McGuire yes representative Earth yes
representative copal yes representative
kcom yes representative Popovich yes
representative Brown yes representative
mahagan yes representative peoples yes
representative luno yes representative
Ames yes representative Burton yes
representative fellows yes
representative Damon yes representative
bricky yes
representative cran yes representative
Weinstein yes and chairman lad yes 18
retained does anybody have to be out of
here it's uh 2 o' 2 o' 25 thereabouts
going 2 okay okay so what we have is one
bill left on the docket
675 685 increases total revenue raised
under the Statewide education property
tax requiring municipalities to remit
excess Statewide education property tax
payments to the Department of Revenue
Administration limiting the authority of
the school districts to make certain
Appropriations and increasing base
discussion
bsur Mr chair uh I think that HB 675 and
HB 772 are the most interesting bills
that we have and both of them uh deserve
to be given a lot further consideration
in the fall um so
much yeah we yeah we don't have
it thank you okay you can pass it around
well as soon as you me make a motion are
going pass around
first he guidance sir discussion we have
an amendment here so we're going to pass
this around to everybody and then I'm
going to look to representative or for
Amendment have a motion sending we yeah
we'll we'll we'll put forth a motion
first but you know on the bill itself
first make
motion okay okay I'm gonna request a
motion from representa spillsbury first
here and then we can go ahead with
discussion
here thank you than you Mr chair I move
OTP on HB
down yeah was there a second on the OTP
motion I'll second represent mire so
represent Earth puts forth OTP on 675
second by represent Maguire SPS SPS
pardon me spills oh represent spillsbury
excuse me representa spillsbury made the
the motion
OTP second by represent Dan
McGuire representative spilsbury you
want to speak to your Mo
motion I would like to uh uh defer over
to representative herf who has an
amendment and I think that will redirect
our conversation okay and I'll ask uh
represent McGuire first though because
he made the second uh do you care to
speak to it um
well I I find this bill very
attractive um
because I I am strongly in favor of the
Rand decision and this um like the bill
we had earlier um it corresponds to that
um
and but I also think that we need this
um this limit on on spending of schools
I mean in in my town um when I moved
there 17 years ago 18 um it uh our our
mill rate was um
maybe1 15 $16 and now it's $10 more you
know and and it it feels like it hasn't
been the town it's been the school so we
need some rols on spending and this
would give us
them okay uh represent you're recognized
uh thank you Mr chair so I would move
amendment number
d05
48h to HB
675 is there a
second second okay the motion to move uh
amending 675 made by representa F and
second by representa Maguire representa
F so this
amendment it's pretty easy to explain it
is picking off section
three from the original Bill and only
section three and this is the component
that restricts the growth of a school
budgets
section
okay
okay further discussion just a clarify
that means starting on line 26 on the
first page and carrying to the second
page
yeah the uh I should make one
modification of what I said
it does make one change in that section
that section refers to time the original
section refers to time frames of three
years and there are four places where
that was that where that reference
occurs and in the amendment that has
been changed to five years okay that's
good each of those
places me my apologies that again the
the so the original amendment I mean the
original bill in section three has a
number of references to time frames
three years there's actually four
references in there for that three-year
time frame and the amendment you'll
notice changes that to five years in
each of those same three four
places thank
you further discussion yes represent
luno so um thank you very much Mr chair
you know I have I have as much a problem
with the amendment as I did with the
original bill because basically had this
this provision uh in it and um and you
know it's it's I I I understand what the
um what the um um sponsors of the bill
are trying to accomplish uh here but um
but I think this is a number one a a
really dangerous methodology to to
essentially lock in place a school
district's um um uh per pupil budget and
and let me explain why that is a lot of
it has to do with with the way the state
of New Hampshire has um has been funding
its public schools and um some of it is
actually because of of the way the um
the Statewide education property tax
works as well but um but in the very
quickly in the nutshell um New
Hampshire's per pupil cost by District
range from a low of $177,000 per pupil
in Manchester to a high of
$44,000 per pupil in um in Newcastle so
by passing something like this what
we're saying is you know what Newcastle
you know what Waterville Valley you know
what Bartlett you know what Littleton
you know what
um you know what you can do you can you
can keep putting on a super strong
educational program uh because you've
always had that that program funded in
your budget a lot of the reason because
of the way the Statewide education
property tax is collected and how the
excess is retained locally so Newcastle
this is great you can you can keep that
up but
Manchester Newport
Pittsfield Berlin Claremont towns that
have struggled to find the resources
necessary to have a a competitive budget
competitive for hiring teachers
competitive for hiring staff compe
competitive to attract families to move
into um IND their communities
competitive so that the students have
access to the program of studies
necessary so they can be competitive out
in a worldwide Global Marketplace it
basically locks these communities and
and Ian we we all know who they are on
you know when we you know when we talk
about them Manchester Newport Pittsfield
Claremont Berlin um and there's a lot of
others around the the the state too so
and you can look up their per pupil
expenses $177,000 for Manchester I can
go right right down at here uh uh 20,000
for where 21,000 for uh West Morland um
16,000 for for Windam so it may actually
have the um the the low um the low point
on there but but it it locks in place um
uh these these budgets with huge OPP
opportunity gaps for students and I
think if we're going to pick a time to
to put in a a Statewide mandated budget
cap we wouldn't want to do it when we've
got so such um inequitable um you know
funding in place right now I think we'd
want to fix the funding have Equitable
school funding and then we can talk
about um um you know a budget cap but
right now this locks in those inequities
and uh and I I can't support the bill
and I certainly can't support the
amendment further
discussion represent papich thank you Mr
chair I shall be very
brief I just wanted to point out for the
record that under uh Roman the Roman
numeral 4 letter B There is a mechanism
to allow the exceeding of this cap
through a 2/3 majority vote which is a
high threshold to clear of course but it
is meant to be a high threshold to clear
and as a former School Board member in
wiam when we struggled for over a decade
to pass a construction
project we learned from our mistakes and
we managed to get the 60% that we needed
deposit after a lot of work it's not
locking it is making it harder to keep
inflate B budgets absolutely but there
are ways for people who want to catch up
who get the support of their you know uh
you representative Damon thank you Mr
chair I share representative Luna's
grave concerns about this bill and I
think the recognition that there is a
2third majority vote to overturn the
budget
cap is essentially a nons
solution the towns that I represent and
many others throughout the
state that are the have not towns and
currently have these inequitably low
School budgets they barely managed to
get a majority vote to pass their
existing school budget now the idea that
they would get a two-thirds vote to
overcome a cap is completely unrealistic
so they would be stuck with this cap
they would be forever the have not
school districts it's not reasonable at
Ames well no surprise I concur with my
colleagues to my right here uh to my
right right oh okay
uh sure your right not your left I'm all
mixed up today yeah after this after the
discussions today on you know whatever
anyway uh yeah yeah this is uh this is
serious stuff and we're uh we we know
that uh litigation
is uh come and gone and right now we're
a mesh in two cases we're waiting for
the Supreme Court to speak and uh they
all derive from inequity from a sense of
uh lack of fairness in the system that
we have and th that sense of uh of uh
this whole system not being fair has
fueled these lawsuits we feel it in our
our work uh seeking reelection we feel
it in the letters that we all receive
and uh
to take a a turn now and put in the way
of Reform a barrier yes the barrier can
theoretically be overcome but in most
places it will not be uh just because a
2/3 threshold is really hard to get over
and uh I don't think it's the right
thing to do
I there may be a time for this but it's
after we do the work that uh we're
facing right now we've got all these
bills that have been come to us we've
just managed to go through them and sort
them out and that's good but uh we've
got more work to to do
uh this is a difficult budget year
because of the uh drop in revenues and
so we may not be able to do all that we
want to do let's uh give this some time
before we uh lock the door so to speak
and and uh and freeze in the current
inequities so that's I I'm definitely
opposed to this thank you repr
mean thank you Mr chairman I have I have
some concerns with this too are we
talking about capping the the the the
taxes into town they say they can only
tax this much increase this much and no
more be the reason that I'm asking that
question is when the town of penut hit
with a 28% increase this year and last
year on special ed they're not going to
be able to cap the way that we're
requiring them to cap there's no cap on
the special budget there's no cap on the
incre in the in the
demand F disc ref
fellows so one reason I can't support
this bill is that um the appropriation
that's made by a school district is an
appropriation of re that spends revenues
from all the sources so in essence if if
this were in effect if the towns if if
the state decided to give the towns more
more money for their school districts or
there was a Federal grant that gave more
money to their school districts this
could keep them from spending that that
extra money because it's this is not
capping what is raised from property
taxes this is capping the appropriation
which is the total
budget and the other reason that I can't
support it is if a town wants a property
tax cap or a budget cap they they can do
that there are statutes that enable them
to do that it's not our business at the
state level to be meddling how towns and
cities manage their
budgets thank you represent
Burton no I'm sorry thank you V still
voting huh I'm GNA call a caucus right
take your time I've got a testimony at
take your time I'll be back at quarter
hour probably just
saying where you going to be upstairs oh
elction yeah yeah
the
e
okay I'd like to go ahead with our
meeting I'm going to recognize
representative F uh thank you Mr chair I
would like to withdraw my motion to
amend the underlying Bill and and I will
withdraw my second okay and i' like to
recognize representative spillsbury Mr
chair I'd like to withdraw my OTP motion
on HP 675 and represent McGuire and I'll
withdraw my second so this is off the
table and it will come up for discussion
next Tuesday it is an early
bill so that takes us through everything
which we had today I think we had a
pretty constructive meeting regarding
the budget and swep and etc etc um we do
have to write some amendments here and
so I I of course I I know that we're
going to have to get these amendments
done here within the next several days
so we can have them ready for that
meeting uh in regard to the amending
language for uh
563 um I ask again uh represent luno
will you work with represent spillsbury
and myself and you can find somebody
else on your side to work too and we can
try to get something going this is just
a group of people getting together write
an amendment and U come back with that
um we have the same issue let's see let
here
education yeah we have had the same
thing we have the same thing going on
there too we need that Amendment for
773 and that's where we're going to have
to decide the pration amount or what
we're going to do there with that
language behind that did you meet with
him about that or we haven't met on it
okay good okay and then we had and 739 I
think we talked
about um
739 yeah yeah that we're going to get
some language from Mar from from Bruce
and Mark okay so then we're good because
those we do need any kind of reports
that are
due represent papovich you have one doe
tomorrow by noon time and two and you
have several okay great well you have we
have a Minority Report on 527 and then I
550 yeah yeah okay good thank you yeah
and uh so with that anything else for
everybody here now you have
representative
675 well there's could be it's not on
the table anymore it's it still has to
be done by Tuesday so there could be new
amendments coming in so it' be nice if
there's any Amendment if the somebody
would do an amendment if they'd send it
to all of us yeah but they don't have to
I know they don't
so in terms of that we'll see how that
one comes it's it's you know it's coming
up there's not going to be any surprises
there
so anything else thank you very much